you know sometimes in life you get a
little low-energy
you know not meaning that you'll fall
and here's the point somebody your old
holidays you get tired of doing the same
thing or some days you don't want to do
something and I had an acting teacher he
says we get back in class and the kid I
just can't acted I can't cry I can't
feel anything and a teacher would go
assume the position and you could always
go what do you mean he goes what do I
mean you tell me well I don't you just
cry just start crying or start feeling
something I'm not really instant what's
going on in your psychology I don't give
a [ __ ] how you feel
we got a shoot so assume the position
and it may fill up a you have low energy
I'm a little low energy today I don't
know probably I mean I have some serious
condition AIDS
you know every time I ate I saw so many
people die so I'm like hey don't say
that yeah because it's my generation of
robots true never talked about the hell
mine now it's curable dying out in the
bull now you remember I'm the Magic
Johnson days it's like a baby here it's
like her P for me we're gonna be with
you we'll fix it yeah clapping feel
you're good that's why I didn't raise my
friend's mother got it and they said
it's you made you know it's actually
better than having diabetes
she said why'd IVs anymore they said
look I mean you just take clothes and
you're gonna control if you're not gonna
die of it you're gonna die something on
medication that she that's so unheard of
though when I was when I remember all
the way all different kind of AIDS well
I did see a lot of people die of it and
and and young people in the prime of
their life so it was so scary too
because in the 90s I got ever getting
the [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] take how did you
stick your hand in my guy [ __ ] ever
did you stick your hand in my face when
I'm getting deep by key today okay Oh
don't I get any shoving match with you
if you want it hey I see your chin down
bro
I'll go I'm low energy but I will go bro
you haven't touched my mouth again when
I'm talking I'm gonna give you one more
chance
hey about yesterday yesterday we were at
the airport and ubers going to pick me
up we're in two different cars oh my get
my car first and I'm right in the middle
of a story my guy so I went shut up
first of all we're surrounded by
somebody waiting for there were so many
people and Brian in the middle of his
flames don't forget me Oh Shona
my cars Joe and hey everybody he needs
someone to listen to this [ __ ] story
oh my god spy town Goldbergs STV quick
there a story I got so embarrassed I
don't do much life doing like my face
got red and I look down into my hand and
I look through my fingers and you are
like this you are hiding behind the
little one are you going to eat that
stupid Prius and that stupid uber pulled
away leaving me and then I'm there and
everybody I felt like everybody staring
at me so I had to pretend that it was
hilarious me so I can't laughing only
did I guess haha ha
hi we're just friends that might story
wasn't boring oh my god like you might
you know we had a long day long tour we
did in those collapses but long
Moontower Comedy Festival and so I had
to bribe my gym my uber and the guy goes
we go down the road I'm tired man
tinnitus I don't know you know I went oh
yeah that's cool man he is yeah he goes
uh listen Brandon um I'm like already
guy I just landed in LA
come on he goes what God what's her name
what's the what happened to the girl and
I'm like Rhonda but I didn't say that my
I'm like Oh waiting and waiting for it
waiting for it he's like what she lost
and he keep going oh my god and I'm like
oh my god our down now we know he took a
left on Lincoln yeah go towards where I
live and I'm like I could just jump out
this moving car and I'd feel way better
canta cousin's creeped out halfway
through goes Rhonda run the rowdy what
well alright Brandon Brandon and I under
around him it's Brandon and Ron neurotic
because I don't do it why'd she stop
here's with a few tweaks here and there
she could have won a lot of fights I
mean no me uh left up here that's messed
up there uh uh who else she liking us
well let me sing like oh ah [ __ ] I'm
gonna jump out of the car yeah I had a
guy I didn't want to talk and I go pick
up my book and I go to start reading my
book and that should be a clear sign
that you know I'm always very polite and
he goes we come from antis I got Texas
he goes ah we're about to go awesome he
goes man hot there it is asking me about
the weather whoo ha ha ha dude I was
like nope it was hell you guys man
when I was down on the border of Texas
and Mexico bro it was so hot it was like
105 I don't think it's not as big here
but not Vegas in the heat I'm like ah I
want to go oh my Kelvin
it'd be nice like I routed him with my
shoe hey be nice you go leave me leave
me leave me you don't think I've ever
been to Vegas do you think from from
just man to man do you think I want to
know about the [ __ ] weather in Texas
oh yeah exactly
no but you know what I did and I leaned
over and I want system you got really
nice tits y'all really nice tits cool
now it's longer curveball oh you're not
a girl you're not a dime piece you're
not on 11 that's the only time I'm gonna
listen to anything you say if you're hot
as [ __ ] and I want to get laid and you
can show me pictures of your dog on your
phone you know what I mean like oh sure
I thought I will stay gonna you'll put
up with an [ __ ] is what you'll do
I'll put up with the aim of it I
literally she could be the worst human
of all that I've dated like oh damn damn
you killed that thought you drowned it
[ __ ] how was that so it's quick yeah
that's crazy girl what's going on you
kill puppies
ah it's awesome oh well hating is
awesome if I can just get laid and then
get away from you now I hate wipe you
please - girl that's crazy
I'm not showing you something to eat yep
oh your rage not hug I like to drink too
much like I never drink man let's do it
yeah coke why not but if your name is
Octavio and you got a dick and you're in
your late 30s funk you know one talk get
a friend and I'm not like I don't want
to talk to you real great about Brendon
how about Brendan he goes I don't want
to wait in the line to the impossible
line for voodoo doughnuts and so
I am going to go to the after-party sort
of the final port party of the Moontower
Comedy Festival figured I'd see some
people and it's just down the way so
then I go to that party walk around like
the old guy that I am and I realize I
don't want to hang out here go back to
the hotel and I read texts I go I waited
so long on the beach like this up so
voodoo donuts and it's new in Austin
it's the biggest voodoo donuts I've ever
seen all I cared about is getting doing
good at all the shows we were grinding
while we're out there and then I was
like I'm gonna treat myself to Buddha
doughnuts but my favorite dumps in the
world the chocolate glaze my favorite
don't want so we it's like I don't know
midnight one yeah morning and the lines
long is [ __ ] like I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm gonna wait in line I do not care
have cold hard cash in my hand
yeah but waiting well I gave it to you
for thing I give me 20 goes getting that
20 standing look like 40 bucks for
[ __ ] doughnuts well if I want to
doesn't know how hungry I'm going to be
thanks daddy
anyways so I mean shark eyes dull smile
Jay Shaab wait in line you leave here's
the party I don't hear from LA all I
want to do I don't want to get a party I
don't care if Pam Anderson or prime
escaping you looking to dance and I'll
psyche dick after Mike no I want to go
to my room do this decaf coffee and he's
done it to my underwear that's all
that's my dream right yeah I even tried
to get you the party I broke this
[ __ ] thing I have a bro party's
legit which is complete like it was
[ __ ] well what do you even mean what
does that mean what does that mean why
would I even say [ __ ] me I'm 50 and I'm
just in a loss to the after party it's
not legit I speak your language like you
know like like thirty thirty a sparkline
parties dope anyways so Brian goes I go
I'm not moving and then I go nice little
face wouldn't of this ugly
let me drive it let me describe it I
just hey guys got your glazed right here
and any spells glazed laa a wise and and
what is it well it sure is the glazed
doughnut kind of sitting half out of the
box touching the sheets all right
already got a problem with it
touching touch the shoot his legs open I
could see his feet in the background TV
and
and millimeters not inches but
millimeters away from that glazed
doughnut
is his fat wrinkly shitty look Agoura
dick Aurora dick is dick his his dick
and I swear to god I'm not an expert but
I swear to god it looked like it his in
heaven post Jack post jacked so Hitler
he loved exhaust it would be humping
sauces like he like if he had a mouth
he'd be going oh look at that I was
really I don't I'm not Breyer I know
brothers died a dog's just glazed
Darlene Gacha machine limp dick jet
exhaust I would touch grace Fraga I put
realize it was I guarantee it that that
directly dick probably touch that donut
at one way they could not otherwise that
big donut in the morning about the [ __ ]
man I was like I go I'm not going I'm
not eating that donut Hey the best part
in all the other dinner while he's doing
so make sure the jock I want to try I
forgot and I you were just furious oh I
woke up in the one I that did all this
though I was starving [ __ ] off I was
furious
oh god that hurt self fun hose out about
the host Jack seahorse the skin of a
seahorse no I don't know wrinkly in the
ground baby open chill when they're all
ashy just look at it look like he's all
tired and wrinkled up hey like over like
when Winkle without a beard [ __ ] fan
become just don't a [ __ ]
oh ah God those great how fun was
awesome them and we had some great food
a great town we went to Justine's our
boy mark like Justin here's a special
place you know if you've seen True Blood
you know where that [ __ ] works the
little vampires I was like that is it
that is the truglide did
it's the True Blood hang out it's the
middle of this grass field and it's so
old school of Nancy and great food and
and there's me I'm a senior under
tapestry the under tab see the cool
undertones be artistic crowd of Awesome
there there's not yes watch it's white
as far as the
why people everywhere rest dressed well
like dandies and I I had to cut a
hipster like 50s vibe but phenomenal had
a couple ladies my age my age you
thought you're so cool how bad did I
want to go home let me sit so before
this after art sold so the way it works
of the Moontower Comedy Festival so
Brian I do finally kid together we have
to fun kid shows one Thursday night one
on Saturday night and then uh before
after those shows on Thursday Friday
Saturday
I have stand up Brian hair stand up then
Brian would have stand up where you saw
my post every to him singing which was
that out will give it will give into
that we get into that so um so we have
that and so once we get done with our
last show on Saturday night then I stand
up late that night we go to Justine's
and so we all we order steak to have the
steaks and frites there fries and for
french fries fried fries and um but
we're watching UFC fights on the table
which is frowned upon like you're almost
not hat well we're in this very cool
French restaurant I fight you have to
fight on Jays phone and I'm chef on you
know and oh sweet did the Vaughn flute
joke kind of oh yeah I demonstrated on
Brian like he gets up from the tail I'm
not going all it yeah you call soon as
what figure out watch this one flew
chunk against kept fighting is white and
I demonstrate and you did it we'd never
see that coming cuz you did it I mean
anger those people I knew that was kind
of easy
so I'd say he's a blue belt level
jujitsu what one already that felt
probably around then but that choke that
he can do is high level brown black like
he's really really good at just I was
amazed that you got up and shoveled you
idolized wrong Brian if I don't get it
and I looked around I was like [ __ ]
these people why my full wraparound my
big asses um I was like you're bored you
barely fit in that restaurant
everyone's I go Brian put me a
guillotine staying guilty and I just
showed Brian up right there by the way
you didn't have to apply any pressure
and that hurt like a mother to badass
Joe roof so anyways watch the fight and
we're gone back loop will forth like
yeah
yelling [ __ ] everyone hates us in there
yeah yeah and then oh ah then I want to
leave it's been a long [ __ ] night man
I saw all I just keep talking [ __ ] about
voodoo donuts I think I was down on
peoples nerves just talking about Donuts
girls would come up to us
guys like very cool you know ever Donuts
that and then I'm finally Brian has
violence like an English teacher he has
a shirt on with a velvet crushed-velvet
portugol bras boss black label look at
it's brown he looks like every history
teacher you've ever had I do thank you
dear House dues on pepper beard no you
did look good yeah
and then these two these two all the
holler they're mine Oh hold on these two
hun oh they their faces look like AZ Oh
babble hold Sal
no I'll try that Navajo don't have that
Saturn we all guys know bags like around
dog we all get all in one goes oh hey
they were not you know explain what a
wife you'll creep stop and talk you know
as one of them new means from Los
Angeles so she knew me because she used
to wait on me one of my favorite
restaurants no longer than an e46 long
time ago so she's love of I said hey
it's me and III didn't honestly
recognize her and but I noticed her
friend was putting a Mad Dog stare on me
oh she's putting the old handbag NAB oh
I call it she was she was raping me with
her eyes
so it was it so I said hi Holly great
fresh year of I pledged in booth I said
hi how are you and she would actually
rather attractive older woman
and when I say older I mean probably
finally for your sake four years younger
than me hey that's how old I am I know
but she was she was not good before she
was everybody young girl I'm saying
surprise 284 no no she's probably 45
both in the 46 we have all the eighties
no don't say that and so and so she said
to me she goes I was just saying to my
friend that's one of the best-looking
men I've ever seen in my life to which I
went well I'm sticking around I'm
sticking around there's nothing I enjoy
more than being admired by women and I
don't care who they are what they look
like or where they're from and I you had
to pull me away from both of those I
told rise to those I must speak those
more ladies
mature milfs no well Hills we're going
to be dry but just don't be sir please
please you're late it's a tractor boys
are males there's Gil all right
then there's mamamoo they were buildings
I'd like the flood ok well they were
they were they were attractive mature
women and we had a nice conversation and
you go hey be my back has killed me I
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here I was
like listen ladies I really appreciate
being admired because I am and I'll see
you later
and I was it less like both their noses
and I anti a sucker for any kind of
admiration or any fan who comes them
goes love your stuff I'm like I stay
there for way too long
okay so we'll safe and even though you
can't get construction workers like
what's up Brian somebody are you guys
doing man something good look I bi this
whole thing I could have waited a little
thing and I'd arch my back yeah you guys
are crazy
dude the best thing at the Moontower
Comedy Festival was the Comedy Jam I
didn't know what we're goddamn comedy
can Brian was singing it so what they do
is they have comics go up there and they
do like a story or a bit and then they
do a song so is Brian who else Adam ray
who was a bee yep he's saying a lot of
Alanis Morissette isn't it ironic isn't
ironic and his story was I'm a good it
might be his bit is so [ __ ] funny yep
very very good comic who else was on
there was Tony and Tony Hinchcliffe who
you killing me killing me with his
comedy hilarious voice not so good there
I said it out loud no holy here's your
listing your voices let's not sing but
might not be let's not sing but he was
singing a very difficult song go
Careless Whisper but his comedy was
Michael slaying me he is I love his
comedy he was killing me check out you
know his partner-in-crime the guy who
does Tony kill Tony with him yeah yeah I
would the the nose from Jeremiah Watkins
yes Jim Iowa right kid that sax player
how about there yeah but he's great
color stuff grand the same we did a set
together ripped my shirt on yeah so he
they're doing kill Tony in Austin and
they're making fun of some guy and they
said the guy was real hostile well he
was on mushroom he ripped the mic out of
his hands and then another like hour
whatever
so Tony and red band just keep playing
along with it
no I'm an would you do for a job if he
has no kill Tony do you have new comics
like a minute to see what they got and
then they critique them you're gonna get
roasted
Tony Red Banner yeah and jermiah wat you
gonna marry my it's very good at
roasting very good she's old on Haunted
Hill no he is [ __ ] get with it but he
so big finally guys he rips the mic out
of jeremías hands Germans like whatever
Tony does what he do and then Jim Iwata
can't go besides being a real-life
Cabbage Patch doll you know I real like
Garbage Pail re-sprout garbage pail kid
I guess the guy flipped out Michaels
crazy eyed fighting them he pushes and
he turned some food ox the Moontower
like [ __ ] towers things
yeah the pill attack them yeah and I not
for you if your community can't deal
with the gradalls and then he was
talking [ __ ] to him on Twitter but then
he was on mushrooms apparently ah
although I've been on mushrooms I
haven't been violent I've just been like
it's just after you stare at a water
fountain for about three hours
um you didn't get arrested though I
think he did or he got be my own dude we
were watching at the hotel we saw that's
rat poo dude we saw a fight between the
Bachelorette and her man and her and
then the Kruger bridesmaid the
bridesmaid the [ __ ] I'm sorry what is
it we call who used to getting married
the woman is getting marinade of all I
the bike ride ride in the maid of honor
oh hey I'm not talking like and we know
that they said that's what it was the
con I'm and I'm not talking like lay
down
I'll talk to Joey Headz on cement
due to both of them both of them eat I
hate I bear bear hug hitting the ground
one on top of the other one slammed her
head pulling hair watching one throwing
punches fantastic we just kept and we
not nothing not a one of those ladies
had been missing a meal not a 100 those
a heavyweight fighter with heavy weight
heavier Club these gals were in the I
mean if they were coming out here now
they're in the UFC they'd have to get
that listen the limits 265 we got to
talk
I mean big-boned gals at throwing
throwing bones or only throwing Heat and
nobody getting hurt there's a lot of
padding going around but I'll tell you
something then her friends are trying to
pull them off and the guy the guy starts
to cry the group the groom he starts to
cry they'll start being about yeah they
start being here talk to him I think if
I could say
I was trying to put it together I
believe that bridesmaid maid of honor
was probably getting fresh with the
brought with the groom and and then the
bride the bride was like [ __ ] this you
could see there was history there it was
beautiful they're a couple but at one
point he booth who look like yeah there
was Texan as well and what am i what
Barbie can you write them every day all
day the groom went the groom went and
any kind of like look like he was like
scratching his throat and he ran into
traffic and I was worried he was gonna
get hit it was just a disaster
she's definitely doing the fussing oh
yeah he's are either bottom oh yeah the
whole thing with homeland was that it
was classy did for I woke up next more
like what in the world just happened
yeah well you know alcohol on that level
in any city is never going to work well
Austin Austin if you're listening sober
up we're down 60 whoo I thought it was a
frat party I'm sure I'm not talking I
was running a gauntlet everyone was
chocolate wasted it was like run Shula
drunking made for that true - weird
right it was weird it was crazy drunk so
at that time at night right that's God
start literally pouring out of the bars
it was like Bourbon Street times 10 and
they don't know what to do and they're
all hanging on each other and I walk
down there to get to our hotel I know I
was worried about I had to yourself I
had to dodge I keep my head down and I
just I started I was literally dodging
bodies I got my voodoo dose which is on
that sixth Street or 5th Street yeah I
[ __ ] Johnny J light jog don't light
jog home it's trouble I feel like yeah
it that's always trouble yeah I'm always
worrying something to pull out of gun
somebody pulls out a gun or a knife and
somebody starts cutting or shooting
there's a lot of cops though a lot of
color it means that there's a lot of cop
has to be a lot of cops gladney odds are
saying Texas when we go to copy shops
want to light roast what the [ __ ] is
going to hit like look you and I don't
like sour coffee because we're men cuz
we're maybe like where we got flying the
talent palette and it is my impression
of your brother ready yeah but the
caffeine is twice as much the caffeine
is twice as much I like it
I put citrus in my coffee I actually put
lemon in my coffee I was like no Jason I
put I mix lemonade in coffee I like to
Catherine all right so you like caffeine
we got to take a cap in pill and drink a
[ __ ] suck on a lemon yeah all right
shut your mouth shut your mouth but we
like a nice dark roast what's good
it's this weird [ __ ] this new kind of
trend of light roast you talk about I
see BICS bull chef when they say you
taste the beam no bounty of roast [ __ ]
off the French in the Italian I'll take
my coffee the way the French in the
Italian drinking your red afro think
they got French press for a reason
that's right I start to telling them
Todd you get that [ __ ] hippy light
roast on my face yeah exactly I easily
cook meat and we roast beans [ __ ] off
lettuce carpaccio back to Justine's oh I
love that about that garlic custard
Louie dude we had garlic sounds
disgusting maybe the best thing we've
ever had garlic bread you sent us into a
pan and put a nice fig jam the first
layer they put that custard garlic on
top yeah oh and also when I'm on the
road I go off my diet yeah you got my
dad one morning I woke up and I just I
mean I couldn't see you at one morning
your mouth was so full that it was
everything I could do not to just to
shake it down shave your shave your face
down throwing and running my mouth we
drink deeply of your mouth it's throw a
wig on you welcome to club yeah then I
die air your eyes get in line he looked
like a giant Asian woman I couldn't be I
did that's racist such a chin Mountain
know what so be it looks like Jen's
brother yeah if I eat a lot I do I was
like wow I like to party though my part
I mean just eat food not drink at all or
simply my party yeah but I was good
though because every now you know you
don't even can I don't drink if I'm
drinking Erica trunk nope never
every girl that's it to do anyways every
morning we'd wake up and work out on
Academy though those workouts man
hashtag sweat City what was the
gentleman who looked like Steve Aoki
taking us through the workout it's
terrible we don't know because he's a
master trainer at the honor Academy he
looks like Steve Aoki and our apologies
for not know a genius it's easy Korean
and white he's a complete badass he's 40
John Wolfe is a badass one how about
one's cat quads one who took us through
two worked out just type two
get your dick out of my face like then
we worked out he had just tights on and
he should yeah with the biggest quads in
the world and that quads that beat us
down with those awesome workouts those
dudes know what they're doing that the
the workouts tbo got Paul says I know
name the Steve Aoki workout it was 30
minutes but it was non-stop it's 30
minutes are like rope kettlebells
tillable swings one and you're a pro
athlete in great shape correct me if I'm
wrong 30 minutes all you need
yeah I love doing that worked I mean not
six times a week but I think for three
times a week yeah hell yeah I love that
work it's not hard on your body right J
shop did with me he's not known for his
cardio he didn't with me about halfway
through goes I'm get some water I went
you mean take a break can you last
outside well it I was worried about Jake
potatoes and do that kind of work out no
he's in shape but a different kind of
shape was he's a big fit kid right we
all sick Brock but um that workout
wanted to scream I was a bit of a beast
at the end there yes it was and I was
worried about Jay Sean again he doesn't
do that yeah it's not easy for him but I
loved it I loved it I mean I that's all
I need I looking a sled doing the ski
machine doing a row machine running on a
treadmill and then before that we did
the complex with the straw bail yeah
straight Gloria pretty cool
Oh fun though man and then we did a
podcast with the Skylar Bros far the
squatters floors all areas lore yeah the
other brilliant those guys are as funny
as it gets and I did their podcast
doesn't [ __ ] can riff on [ __ ]
like you get in a subject and they just
riff they're like it's basically to two
minds against one they date they're so
in sync
they're so able to layered do you ever
see on it I want to bring up him on the
show but did it a silly [ __ ] question
but there's that Sean vhn the twin was
just a competition of twins it's so they
separate in two different houses huh and
then they'd only get together when their
Tom tissues but they didn't do well when
they're separated right like when
they're separate they had like anxiety
and freaked out because they're always
together with this exact same and then
during the competitions you'd have to do
what one the other was thinking is right
we like to at the end the elimination to
boy get kick the house
they'd ask questions so they'd asked one
question do so they that's one question
at the same time and if you had the same
answer you get a point dude they were
right most of the time yeah right yeah
it was like as a kid what was your
favorite show growing up as a kid or
what's your favorite kind of bread and
they're always ding right Dean like they
knew each other better name I've never
seen anybody more connected than Randy
and Jason Sklar and they're not are the
other night you guys are you feeling
yeah okay are they the nicest guys in
the world super nice and funny hilarious
you had a great great hilarious people
we got to go in my I'm going to talk to
Justin my agent who Toria is it I want
to go back to awesome I want to do it
right because the comedy tour and I
apologize those who didn't get tickets
those comedy festivals it's not on Brian
eyes so they invite us you got to be
invited economy festival and then they
sell badges typically not tickets for
finding the kid they sold I think 200
tickets right but in general they sell
bad so you can see Brian town stand up
Brent shop stamp then you can go to find
kid then you can go see da Moreira or
Jay Pharoah or you know integral whoever
whoever but that's what it's not just
for the fireman kid right so we want to
go back to you know like six months and
do it right do a one big-ass buy in the
kitchen definitely see that let's call
it six months and kill it six months and
just do tunes young at the Peter Mel
just kick it kick it kick it wouldn't be
that either I gotta tell you we do to
show no I want one I don't want to i
want one big grand [ __ ] so show yeah
yeah grand hug show called the grand hug
oh so we didn't eat that we didn't eat
that damn barbecue that dead Audrey
always brings us to we were so busy
being slaves right food oh that's the
best type of I've ever had in my life
when I tell you shut up remark this
recurrence way he took me that I looked
on like god damn it's good my problem is
I just can't stop something skill I just
want to keep order order like that fried
crab rice yeah
I have great tacos too man tacos are
good you know woman ham yeah we went ham
there was one more thing about Austin we
didn't see the bat because I saw it on
video too and I don't care
and I don't care about bats because I
would have been like mom look at all the
bat that's Batman senator dibble fun
yeah
I would released Hawks Denis that's what
eats bat Oh Al's do I'll be the bad luck
owls are straight-up predators Al's in
Harlan yeah out ideally I would kill cat
hey with it no I don't but you and J
wouldn't shut up about birds
I read that lunch it ruined my lunch man
he's just tied my bird well we're pretty
deep when it comes to burst oh yeah your
anti bird at that lunch we were talking
about the birds and their stupid pet to
have yeah they were doing it yes you can
I was talking about my parrot I used to
rub his tummy and all day Brian took 13
minutes to bring up a YouTube video of a
guy rubbing a brain up here it's bellies
like unless it's your bird I don't give
up that's like saying I play basketball
and showing a highlight clip the LeBron
James like all right
that's not you who gives a guy guys are
like that where I started talking about
my kid I started talking about something
he did and Brennan goes hey man you're
not allowed to tell me about anything
like that though should super bored
right Brian in the car he's like dude
you know what my son this and my wife on
it whoa whoa what are you doing right
now
I'm not your next-door neighbor what the
[ __ ] me where's Brian yeah hey don't
you're closer Brian was like in us all
right you went oh you're right yeah I'm
right would I ever do that - sir
Oh bro you Joanna the other day what are
you doing so folks do you don't know did
you see how Chris Pratt he'd handled it
very well Chris Pratt just said
something like he goes you know what man
you know I come from blue-collar roots
and I feel like Hollywood doesn't show
any like blue-collar stories about like
regular blue-collar workers in the
Midwest just kind of white guys or doing
their thing and people Twitter they go
well there are about a thousand movies
like that and here's the list and Chris
Pratt just looks at all three she goes
[ __ ] like including this year like a
mattress by the sea just goes I'm not
and he goes yeah you know it's probably
stupid thing to say I'll on that there a
ton I'm talking about blue-collar kids
heaven awesome it's like that's how you
deal with it just just realize it's like
laughing me and my friends will talk
likes to waste like god damn guy so
they've done Studies on that what do
they say guys need a point there's got
to be a point to what you're saying
nobody please don't
don't tell me about you and your wife we
made for dinner last night go ahead tell
me that story they use so can i why my
wife decided to get a little okay hey
that's really rude I didn't get to my
story I don't care that's what we're
doing on let me pay no sorry good my kid
just took it smelly
excuse me that's what we're doing from
now on that's super a real shitty story
super rude I could not wait for my uber
to come to state you're in the middle of
some terrible storm like we've been
together non-stop other guy where the
[ __ ] the super I'm gonna jump in a
random mover or I'm just gonna jump into
traffic the killing kept looking
prettier a little strong with a
six-month winglet yeah that's cool so
anyway inspector story
ah Wow four is it actually what I don't
know that but the thing is I foxy
doesn't get it I don't want to listen
indoors so she kept on anything all
right even get to the end of my amazing
stuff say sweet beige you Jesus baby
Jesus how did you fare in your
predictions of the fight so then we
applied for five we never brain did you
stirs yeah
you got the Cub Swanson of course
standard you got the OSP standard you
got what was the other fight that was
Saul was the other side some great
fights man I'll remember Jake
Ellenberger
I yeah Harry I said I decided to hate
that fight for Jake
I hated that fight for Jake but I can't
paint as my friend Jake but if I was
betting on a take Perry why did you hate
that fight just cause Perry hit so hard
and I yeah for every reason known demand
oh you know I took lows in Lausanne up
over Stevie Ray so I went I wonder did
you get away I went of course I went one
I always take Iaquinta and we should
talk about him but I went let's see one
I took lead to get Jonathan so I went
one two three four five six out of seven
not bad not bad not bad Brian uh Jake
Ellenberger for Diane Brian Brian now it
happened to Jake at this point price she
gives brain check
that was a horrible knockout and my
favorite I went to him when he didn't
get for honesty she goes the years he
puts tweets the bonuses he retreats but
[ __ ] yeah he's got a mouth i retweeted
today this morning now it was like
quotes from my Clinton Nashville and you
just like what the [ __ ] he was the I'm
on TV the car I'm driving I could be
doing anything in the world because I
love fighters will get paid [ __ ] they
bringing in Reebok it was cool it how
about the fact he goes yo if you're
looking for a house I'm moonlight as a
realtor but he said today goes I think
on MMA hour with Hawaiian he goes
serious inquiries only don't people
won't be a fantastic you so hilarious
man I don't know what his objective is
there but is it possible he wants to I
just think he's over like you making
money elsewhere Fighting's a tough game
you know it's I don't know what his
motive is it I love what he's doing
though you need got to speak up like
this cuz everyone's so scared and yet
this Jersey kid he doesn't give a [ __ ]
speaks well looks good gonna be writing
the top 10 now just starts Diego Sanchez
um I I believe he should have won a
knockout of the night but again you can
talk to [ __ ] you know do this thing's
they're not gonna do you any fate half
not getting discretionary bonus your
highlight can be featured on the main
card next I don't think he gets it over
Mike Perry Mike Perry that dad knock I
was crazy that that elbow is do I mean
that was yeah but I quit took all that
time off came back from an injury
he's a co-main event I guess I love the
legend Diego Sanchez yeah and starches
him start to say it with a minute 40 in
the first round
you know Mike Perry you learned that
elbow Jake Elbert won the first round
yeah and and Jake's been knocked out
kind of a bunch lately man you know it's
it's a you know you want his last fight
you know but it's a tough go yeah they
Rumble even asked Jake Ellenberger to
retire
she said something online have to job
today yeah Jesus Christ I think it gets
to a point where most guys you can tell
since I do let's what are we doing here
and you know Jake has a kid a young one
and I love Jake man one of the great
guys I should
on that breakdown he's a good dude but
the thing these cards have been
delivering men like they're great cars
just not getting a lot of hype they're
just not well I mean that seems to be
the biggest problem and I don't know why
they want is it because now that it's
this big corporate thing there's nobody
at the helm I don't think they know what
to do it I think there's a new guy with
social media like Ike went to posted you
know they trying to hype his fight and
goes he reposting goes dude this is
footage from four years ago like the
[ __ ] yeah and it's just like oh if you
were fighting DC in the ASEAN what emoji
would you use [ __ ] yeah a thirty year
old girl's not tuning in to vit now what
grown man see like who I'd use the devil
horns right when you guys doing huh
we'll figure it out there's a huge fight
this weekend though not a UFC yes he's
taking some time off before that huge
Dallas card but uh there's anti joshua
force which goes Saturday I mean you
know and Showtime is the biggest
heavyweight fighting I can't remember I
can't wait to see that fight long long
long time I cannot wait done Showtime NH
villains last time they did that yeah so
just to show you how big it is
Joshua sold-out Wimble D I think it's
wimp wimp lemon Moulton no no it's
Wimble Wembley Wembley Wembley Wembley
thousand tickets in under two hours that
true Wembley Stadium is wow that's a big
Rolly pull up Wembley Stadium take a
look at how big this is for a sec
for a boxer and people say boxing is
dead I beg to differ one of the Meritor
they say that everywhere else little
yeah
yeah I don't even nothing to say boxing
dead cuz I haven't heard anybody say
that but it just sounds awesome
no it's like I look at the size that
[ __ ] stadium guys get a better
picture mm what oh [ __ ] come on look at
that look at that enormous look at that
it's like let's go that is not which
goes a huge draw in Europe so you're the
best of both worlds it's kind of like
this young line for steel that mm-hmm
such a great fight I'm stuck with you
what do you think about something
I'm going back and forth like that's the
truth I don't know yet
yeah do my research right now go back
and forth mmm such a good fight though
yeah I think it's not like 1 o'clock 2
o'clock our time oh yeah and Porter and
her toe fight this weekend did you watch
the fight I sure did last night I only
saw the highlights ah Porter just put it
on and kind of out class and we'll
pressure pressure pressure and that put
them away Porter's a monster he wants
that rematch with Thurman yeah he gets
mandatory burns mandatory tie against
Thurman man to be honest I thought he'd
beat swimming last time see what
happened who's all that left that damn
rat feels article like that sucks yeah
we took those girls trying to pick up
talent at the bar
hey man you can get some Trinidad's do
some car in a band of at voodoo don't
gonna train my fat link' is that you're
really done scoffing now we don't coffee
yeah you brought it from us I like what
you said voodoo doughnuts coughs well I
could talk Oh gross
all right let's use some current events
all right
first current event we didn't ever talk
about this suicide thing with the Aaron
Anna's his Bible verse Scrolls on his
head you know what I think Dean you know
I think is that that's a very small
forehead so it had to be buddies all at
night yeah you you clean him up the exam
you can fit one sentence on your
forehead like it right John 360 on my
forehead but you want more than that
can't do it yeah that's what yeah this
forehead yeah um how about they're
saying this this have you seen this chin
the talking about he had a gay lover
that's the next one go ahead go into
that well I mean you pretty much said it
they think he was actually bisexual had
a gay lover and that's one of the
reasons why they think he killed that
other guy another code Odin Loudoun
lawyer yeah why was he was gonna tell
people or extort him for money or
someone Josh what he doesn't realize I
know around the homies and like that
that cuff click use with it's frowned
upon
but in society he would have got so much
more notoriety insane feels like yeah
I'm bisection I thought girls I thought
dude I'm good look I happen to be one of
the big eyes a handsome ass dude I
happen to be one of the best football
players in the world I'll Jack you off
I'll suck on your titties what's up
you've got so much more thing that would
have been good but I here was a lower
booyaka of a suck on your titties whoa
Helen could cut where's the producer do
we have a lag on this barber yeah he's
such a good looking guy he would have
been the toast of America based on that
I'm big how much support de England
Jenny I'm straight and I'm a batter how
much support to Caitlyn Jenner and
that's after his or her career yes poor
describe how your Nana's got grander if
you just didn't kill anyone he just rode
this wave you would have got so much
love it's crazy so thank you and then
you fight for [ __ ] the gender
bathrooms and all that you do you [ __ ]
up well did you say what the note says
like I just love sucking your dick but
they said the law law enforcement did
say that it was for three people like
one suicide note was for his fiancee
yeah one for the daughter and then one
for the gay lover complicated guy man
and now he's on 24/7 suicide watch
that's interesting though because so
that would have been the case so that we
know that that Odin Lloyd checks that
out realized or in addition to the
report explained an intimate
relationship the former New England
Patriots player Lesley had with a male
classmate in high school was reportedly
at the center of the investigation to
Odin Lloyd's murder Wow
they were bullied keep your mouth shut
and still be alive huh that's he's got a
family man Kyle I'm terrible man it
really is well so you know you're
bisexual
you were [ __ ] one of the first girl
once were rescued and then one for his
daughter and two sorry three different
like money's being sent from his account
one for his fiancee one for his daughter
and then one for that guy you know one
of the things that's human beings men
like they can have a very evil side then
they can have a tender side I mean yeah
he also might have but you know but like
in in his world like it's the ideal
world like your life's over of your
friend
find out you're gay or bisexual so he's
like [ __ ] right you're right um I'm
sorry to turn this over to the other
side but it says celebs who died and no
one said a word did that woman die who
is on know they do that they let that
I'm some stupid [ __ ] with the other
girl just all trolling oh you got shine
now listen internet yeah look in the
internet site I did I'll say like six in
six ways to increase your penis size you
click on that huh now cuz and then I got
to draw a line on it even this look at
that
it's so stupid let's not acknowledging
that [ __ ] ah um so her dad's brain
was taken to Boston University where
science scientists will study it for
repeat trauma suffered I think it's what
I was listening this is the bummer nice
office my favorite like sport shows for
steak with Stephen a and Max Kellerman
and Malik um shout to Molly
um it's disappointing to hear them who
they've never played football grow he
barely played in the NFL there's gonna
be no CTE that it doesn't mean no brain
trauma you have one enough career Mike
oh my god I do your [ __ ] research why
were they join football since he was
seven it'd be from seven - what is he 27
that would be at least 24 those 20 years
like that or 15 years we're gonna swear
it's gonna happen I'm sorry well not
even high level doesn't matter what
lovely plant but at a young age when
your brains trying to form you're taking
hits that's when they say a lot of
problems occur so for him that brain
trauma I think they're in be surprised I
don't think it's what it you could chalk
it up to maybe that's the reason why he
was so kind of bipolar maybe but he also
had childhood trauma then he tossed CT
brain trauma in there they toss it toss
in gang-related stuff he toss you know
it's like there's all this adds up so I
think brain trauma can play a role in it
but it's not everything I think he's
only six one time as me no yeah he
wasn't really tall I thought his ex your
height
man the funerals today right what a
shame for everyone involved though it
really is it's just a wasted life and go
down to his funeral for me Jameson Lance
oh sure
Monday April 24th um what to say about
it
they're just blocking it and being
they're sending a lot of cops over to
the security area
sure just in case mother fiance servos
defense attorneys for I wonder if any of
his teammates former teammates Oh 100%
oh my god I'd be right most of them yeah
yeah like the bouncy brothers where he
was like a brother to okay teammates
loved and Hernandez hey they really yeah
good dude in the locker room
yep well that's what I mean it's right I
mean yeah right you kill people but you
know people probably had a good good
memories of them and it like it like I
was saying not ever nobody's hundred
percent evil I mean some people maybe
but rarely rarely that it's complicated
it oh there you go the guests included
Micah Murray's Pouncy Blaine and spikes
the doctors checking out his brain his
wife defense attorney payment the
checking IDs for them to get into Wow
because they think something's gonna
happen
I'm guessing high security won't do the
gang affiliation and help anyone either
now and then Odin Lloyd's family's
probably super upset then the one guy
bad guy
there you go hey we got shunned I hate
them so maybe they're looking for
revenge because a lot of people think
one of the reason to commit suicide so
the Oise and Lodz family can't get
access to any of his money oh that's not
what I asked you guys because they were
saying that there's all these different
legal things that happen right so he's
not even a murderer if he commits
suicide because the trials is that his
appeal appeal its opinion or whatever so
yeah so those two convicted murderers
that he got off of you know yeah
according your cornea allegedly he
didn't do those and he's found in court
they didn't do them and then the the one
they did it can make for the serving
life sentence he appealed that so they
were going through the peeling where he
kill himself for that so they can't
touch his money now it's crazy and it
goes to the family
right up legally the family another
situation where he realized he felt like
he was worth more to his the people he
loved dead and then he was alive but
also I don't think he was that appeal
wasn't gonna work out like yeah but the
evidence is pretty stacked yeah life in
prison or you know so so what is the
final count Odin Lloyd it tried to kill
the guy who shot me
loving guy and then there were two other
where's that basic and then he's
connected to a drive-by in college but a
reason for life people yeah and they
also said he smoked synthetic marijuana
the day before he died
so you do in prison all right I do some
weird [ __ ] yeah well alright what else
you got - and that's a bummer just all
the way around - bummer
sure is guys just such so many
opportunities though he had have done so
much for the gay lesbian bi transsexual
community and then yeah I mean it's just
Chan to Arab trouble than me yeah I
don't like the tragedy you know you know
enough prison suicides way way more
likely than you getting killed by an
inmate zero way higher a lot of suicide
up way more it's a boy big issue then
you getting killed by an inmate you know
that I'm I didn't uh yeah there's your
[ __ ] dropping knowledge and I get it
done when you're 23 24 and you're
looking at the rest your law or all 40
and you got certain lies this that
sentence like this is terrible yeah hand
me that [ __ ] blanket out of there
close the door yeah that's how they do
it you know so my dick they always hang
themselves on the blanket yeah
next you know to take away blankets and
wear that thanks Aaron and there's no no
one just like it
hey more Bibles thanks bro well when
they're it when I've been in the psych
ward of prisons and they give you a
nylon smock a nylon smock that you wear
and you have no pillow no sheets you
haven't seen the beds
yeah there's steel it's like this steel
go to sleep on that and how your back
feels in the morning often usually
commit suicide so you commit suicide
yeah you're in a glass aquarium and by
the way I went and saw that in
miami-dade County Jail
and it was so traumatizing to me that I
almost began to cry and the guard who
was running things said he saw my face
I'm a macho guy I was around a bunch of
dudes and I was having a meltdown having
having trouble not holding it trying to
hold together and he goes he goes you
looking at him we got no he goes get him
out of here man you can't do this to him
you can't just bring in Las Vegas
you don't just bring somebody who
doesn't know what this is about that
happen don't do that to him he got mad
he goes don't bring in a civilian
without getting him right I say when I
left he was saying that the guy goes you
don't bring him in and you know he
doesn't he's not useless he didn't know
what the [ __ ] to expect that's shocking
do this rap is get out happen to me
I broke out into psoriasis my legs I had
red patches all over my [ __ ] thighs
and and Chen - yep and I said that's how
badly about it was when I saw it I think
a were clean we should go do that it's a
cool exciter it's unique experience I
didn't Denver I love doing that lay beef
I am ain't nobody runs those le prisons
and help jails give the finest kid crew
a shout-out via email the finally kids
at G mean I buy the kid shop at penny
male Dynacraft ring but it's just mosey
on through so we have something to talk
about because I I watched locked up
every night well a night patty Jenkins
who our friend who directed Wonder Woman
and had written this script on I'm in
prison she did that she got to walk
through State Penitentiary all I do I
don't bring no you know I don't hear a
door now and she said that was wild was
that she basically was just she in a
guard and another guy who knows a lot of
the prisoners who works for them
basically had free access and just
walked through the jail I was not going
to shake you know I was open up you know
they talked about you know not by going
on I'm like [ __ ] pi room [ __ ] like
it's not that's fine I can go down
probably not no intern and uh oh yeah
fine ah I bet you don't [ __ ] with this
guy UFC guy who wants some who's was
shot stole you coming Jim yeah this guy
right here UFC and then we just do a
real-life movie like undisputed Yuma
with Wesley Snipes and King reigns and
you gotta fight your way out of jail I
do that's what we do and you me
back-to-back yeah and they're just
trying to [ __ ] us well it's not up in
here how many they got up in here I
don't think they were like this may just
be trying to stab us now they're all I
can Hernandez we trying to get to our
glory holes and we gotta fight him bro I
don't want this Mel like this movie and
I want to star in this movie no with you
need I'm not starring in the movie over
I'm not starring in gang cornhole crazy
zombie it's called it's got locked up
locked up with Korn hey Tommy locked up
G locked up cornhole crazy
these guys are cornhole crazy locked up
Ryan and Brendan are locked up and these
guys around the core know crazy locked
up locked up what happens in jail stays
in jail and he kids gay it gets cornhole
crazy locked up Brian Brian Brian bread
take the wrong turn they mess with the
cornhole game that's right there it's
dawn they gotta try to fight the
cornhole gang off and guess what they
roll or they lose ha they lose or yet do
they win they lose repeatedly they'd
lose more time win 91 that's right and
most of the doctors what you're into you
could say they hit the jackpot
don't don't watch this movie for
dialogue because when the guy wrote it
the dialogue is just and shut up shut up
spoiler alert right and Brenda get
hogtied as the corn old gang runs a
train and all they do is they've been
gagged another part of you and it's
looking into into each other's eyes with
horror as they're taking their turns its
bits a line as long as the ones you see
at Disneyland or for voodoo doughnuts
are they getting they're not get ride to
brew dogs they're getting involved in
Brian Brennan's you're going home
now this is a spoiler Brian they forced
a wig and makeup on and he stopped
fighting just kind of gave in to a guy
Brendan fought his heart out but at the
end of they ended up losing from
exhaustion
Hinkel it's probably got hockey Don
watch the physio get [ __ ] Don by the
end man he screams I'm 50 all right they
pull your skin blond wig and at that
anti Duke locked up and they show up
with drugs and I [ __ ] become addicted
am i walking cornhole walking looking
cornhole I'm a walking cornhole I was
you just want to stay in or your [ __ ]
well I need my fix hey guys I'm 50 but
they be like even whoops robbed another
Bank
what's up fellas yeah here this is I got
older ah man he's got great butt hair
let me shave this [ __ ] down
Lamarr get in here with a straight razor
no they're gonna wash ya ah oh I so what
is a whistle my girl got a free girl and
they only be allowed to eat salad so
things were broken over there is so over
sorry so so excited hey my girl got I
forget what kind of wax not Brazilian
some other wax I was like god I feel
like that'd be nice to do my booty hole
in balls did you ever do that they call
it they called the BB balls him I will
say that I keep it I keep it well
clipped under there would you do the wax
I don't like dingleberries you do the
legs I don't think I would do the wax I
don't like I said
ask him how to do for guys and you got
to get on all fours and then spread your
feet yeah you would like that you would
enjoy it you would enjoy it and I
believe in my heart and soul 100% that
you're not only going to do it but
probably already have so I try to break
a nice break in your lights on this
pocket first of all I am appalled but I
am I expected from you can I carry your
[ __ ] rump hole is about as smooth and
I feel like you a bad idea I feel like
this hair down there for a reason I feel
like that would be a bad idea I think
you should only you know how they have
to get like the tape from the balls of
those you know yeah well Brendan Brendan
that is so disturbing to me okay you
pursue to get your damn ankles near I'll
put you put your ankles on my shoulder
I'm a professional dudes that's
someone's job
I know put your dollars you got to go
once a month it's usually a large
Russian woman who never smiles not my
girls is a pretty black onwhat that's
problems that I would need to do like ah
I'd rather have the big warlock to
handle it then some pretty girl or done
that I'll take a guy I mean in other
words it's a dude who's like who's like
I got a hole here then put the UM put
the lip of the wax the guy was like this
guy's like hey I got to do it right
that's how it goes brother no am i all
white that's what I call Eastwood doing
it no you're gonna walk in my oh hey
yeah my girl guys like everybody I do I
got to do is ideally should do how
[ __ ] your [ __ ] and you want to look
wait after this well you'd only do Emma
watch your ass and will you pass out of
this mouth I'm gonna paint this white
this this wax on just going to hurt a
little bit but nor but when a piece of
leather - on guys bite bite to Dallas
letter sorry but they got wax in your
ass it him beat them I'm gonna hold this
cool cloth against a pole believe me it
ain't been diesel buddy no no I want to
talk outside of his mouth she's kind of
a guy works his hands what else you got
chin I was weird
hey remember when you kept going on too
big a bit I mean it's over a man go how
dare you god damn your business just
keep you're the one who did you gotta
use you're the one who let the genie out
the bottle I just said lock down don't
ruin a while if you don't want the genie
to come out don't rub the Bob get the
genie the [ __ ] back in what else gets in
if you posted this on Instagram let's
hang on bang the Korean UFC fighter who
is getting investigating out for fight
fixing it has anymore come out about it
so they found out that like hold on uh
taken bang and Leo kind so young bang
wheels along here about the bang / [ __ ]
great great clothing scan easy it's the
bank on site fixing scanned
or is it comes bang there's your next
porno reality kings oh what he got well
so they didn't really nail down the
persons in the beginning but it was that
fight with Leo consequence yeah take
advance its [ __ ] so if you know the
story there's they're about to get in a
fight and bang was supposed to lose and
he apparently is dealing with the Korean
mafia which is we're already crazy in
itself do you know much about cream
mafia chin just through movies and TV
like what do you know about it that they
all dress in black they drive black cars
same as a Japanese Yakuza they pretty
much you know extortion they they'll ask
you to give you money give them money
for protection yeah you have no choice
in the matter
yeah you don't fool [ __ ] with the craze
I have the full tattoos like the Yakuza
they do tattoos but that's not like a
big thing so what I heard is that a lot
of the Yakuza actually are ethnically
Korean yeah yeah I heard so I don't know
how did you do not wanna mess with the
Yakuza no they they say how they have
double hon no I watched the whole thing
on on Vice land about the gang culture
in Japan and Korea and with the Yakuza
like they're not accepting a lot of guys
so now there's like there's all these
little weird like gangs forming and
they're like going against the it cuz
it's nasty [ __ ] man they fight well now
but so these guys they end up correct me
if I'm wrong here chin so they had a
fight they were both Korean they decide
to fix a fight one was supposed to lose
he gathered I was like nah [ __ ] that I
like being here wins the fight
screws the whole thing up now the Korean
mafia is like you did what give us our
[ __ ] money kind of so the other guy's
not Korean I don't know what Leo Koontz
is but so the Korean guy dealt with the
Mafia they gave him a money or they said
if you throw the fight we'll give you I
think a hundred thousand Korean Won and
that's like a ninety or eighty eight
thousand dollars in America hours they
said do that and then all of a sudden
everyone started realizing that uh the
Korean guy is going to take the fall so
the bet started coming in like crazy at
the last second this is why the show
upset look it says the organized crime
figures they wager two billion Korean
and that so that's one point seven mmm
dollars on coots to win exactly so it
came it came in last minute so the USC
officials went hey guys something's up
here there's a huge sway and then the
betting odds it's changed dramatically
we're gonna find out if one of you guys
doesn't fight we're going to investigate
you they said that so freaked out to him
bang so the last minute hey man forget
that this is me right now Taeyang the
UFC officials are way less dangerous
than a bunch of Korean mafia guys that
probably bet way too much money on this
oh that's like he went to the police
although you'll see if there's a job to
do is send you [ __ ] Reebok kids to
discipline you know cream mafia look
kill you yeah they're gonna take your
qfe like here take this these Reebok
pumps and the kids you gotta win for
life yeah it's not like the Korean mafia
it's not like they're like ah let's
forget about it
it's not like they have bad memories so
they cut your face and eyes off yeah
my Korean Taekwondo GG said is on Korean
is uh 20 years a very short time for me
there's no problem as imma wait on some
way American people are forgetting on me
come on man I don't [ __ ] with you please
yeah great yeah we'll see action I would
what people don't realize is so I posted
this do my god you'll see so [ __ ]
cricket you see I'm not going to do with
this nothing to do with it do you see a
note there no knowledge on this going in
they have nothing to do with this now
they're not part of this in any shape or
form what else you got alright I'm sure
you guys have seen this already the lady
that was crying on the American Airlines
right I haven't seen it's gonna break my
heart the video kind of doesn't show
much it just shows her let's see if I
can play a little bit of [ __ ] wins Jess
yeah be with her [ __ ] baby so check it
out so she she's like balling the video
only shows her bawling for like a couple
of minute or two but then they're saying
that the one of the flight attendants or
it could be a gate attendant was taking
her stroller away cuz she's not allowed
to bring the twin double-wide stroller
into the airplane standard she was she
was warned ahead of time you can't bring
it in but she brought it in anyone see
this is the problem we talked about this
with a guy who's a medic what's our boys
the mark mark Lyford yeah you know not
mark
mark was a mere paramedic well yeah yeah
Medicaid what he's like it's difficult
man could you see stuff and they give
them every opportunity to get out like
listen if you do this this what's going
to happen please get off the plane
please don't bring you on a plane please
do this
listen you hold up the plane what about
everyone else on board like dude I have
[ __ ] places B don't bring your double
stroller on this and I don't think
should ever use physical violence ever
ever ever but both are at fault here hey
lady don't be a jackass and try bring on
a double [ __ ] wide stroller not only
that so but there is sign to be said
about this so the whole plan has to
leave ok people have somewhere to go
if somebody says I'm not leaving this
plane until you allow my stroller on
well we all know that that's not
possible there's no room it could even
be a safety issue there are a lot of
reasons you don't have strollers I have
traveled with a stroller with my
children what we did is we would check
the stroller at the gate that door
that's the rule there's no confusion
here so don't bring the stroller on like
a spaz and like a selfish person or
maybe like a crazy person and make a big
scene nah lady we'll get off the plane
just get off or poor baby don't get off
well don't bring a double-wide stroller
and then refuse to get off yeah both at
the both of the wrassles the way they
dealt with it could been handled better
I think you're dealing with that's the
thing okay so the the reason why this is
even a big issue is because someone on
the plane you know was videotaping it
and she put on her face book oh this
guy's trying to start a fight with the
customers and then he hit the girl and
almost hit their kid that's all I was
right but he didn't at not there's no
footage of him hitting the girl and what
I'm hearing from witness accounts from
you know because they're kind of going
back and forth different wind is too
strong different things
some witnesses said she was she was
yelling and you know being loud with one
of the guys and actually pushed them
when he was trying to pull the stroller
out of here believe it and the stroller
accidentally as she pushed him oh there
you go but this is the cold way I live
and she gets on there first like you
know who's this United or what is my
American Airlines American Airlines
isn't getting get on there like a this
is what happened like date now I don't
think sweet American allies didn't film
any go and look this what this lady's
doing right now it's just unprofessional
but every
one else's so you get this one side of
the story first oh my god there's an
issue with the airlines now [ __ ]
American Airlines American item no not
really yeah like we tried everything
possible shaky on this double-wide
[ __ ] stroller we told her get off
look our guy tracking it down while he's
getting down she attacks him he's
getting down hits her on accident and
now you guys are trying to cry welfare
and then another guy another passenger
ran up and talked to the one flight
attendant or a gate attendant we don't
know who he is exactly it he went up to
goes if you talk like that to me I would
drop you I would knock you out I'll take
you out and the guy the tender goes get
out this is not your business you know
sit down don't come on to like this and
then there they're accusing the flight
attendant for trying to start a fight
with some guy god that's what I'm trying
to find their way through usually though
cause if enough people are videotaping
this is pretty easy to see how
ridiculous and also some mob and tell ya
get up Johnny stop [ __ ] down yeah that's
it I think that's what I need some guys
like guys guys well I'm like dude did
you not see that yeah
get the [ __ ] yeah I can do [ __ ] yes a
profile yeah you're knocked out and now
you've been a bully sit the [ __ ] sangre
what are you doing exactly don't be an
ass are you sure you're really delaying
the flight yeah and where's the marshal
here where's my airline just hire a lot
of ex UFC fighters to just be on there
to just kind of be like excuse me sir
not an Air Marshal but I will put you in
a chokehold if you behave what terrible
job that Neil I all the time
Liam Ellison who's one of the top
grappling coaches in all of the world
and send some vision bronze who's the
Air Marshal for and he'll hop hop in
Marshall he was like it was the
boringest job
AB fer I would fly in planes non-stop
nothing ever happened he goes in one
time he got a plane he flew all the way
to like Kuwait today there was a suspect
on their hit the farmer out turn out the
guy was just a guy taking a piss like
what to help you like no get back on
playing now go back to LA in 24 hours
later God not because the chairs or
anything happened I think imagine
sitting on a plane that long I'd go
crazy kill me yeah you can't read you
got to be working I mean you can you can
read but when they're getting on you'll
be alert
but it's Abby's man no thank you what's
the longest fight you has a
then on me Brazil 14th I went to
Thailand so I did it was probably about
15 16 my dad
I do they're literally trying to a big
brown breakdown live in Australia yeah I
said how much telling the flying bar I
heard it I'm dying to go how long flight
all I don't know man - I don't know man
honestly dollar I'm see I've seen first
crack take anything first ASEAN dollars
yeah honey dollars I need great white
exhibit need a lot of money honey money
and I need guarantees he great does that
own can I can you show me up [ __ ]
black tip shark I'm bummed a little
shark come on let's run around no this
give me a sold-out show in Perth or some
[ __ ] like them like whiny show up dude
they took him on a great white house he
had Joey shows a black tip he [ __ ]
left be left you went back to state in a
huff yeah and there's any problem I saw
walrus Trotter and show them a regular
old alligators yellow piston latinum
what did I say you only swim with a
salty ones oh yeah see some [ __ ] honest
get salty and I need that in the
contract it needs in bullet points
guarantee DC great white shark
guaranteed to see saltwater croc
guaranteed to slap a koala bear
guaranteed to wrestle kangaroo why do
you want to [ __ ] atop a qualify there in
poor mom why did it do any shape in
those not a fight you on your [ __ ]
feet and they have chlamydia you know
that you every one of them has it they
carry chlamydia yeah Alec Amano that one
of my home no I got everything do you do
ticket drop it I swear to God I went to
the koala exhibit and my dick fell out
of my pants okay I'm pretty sure can you
google at just make sure though I'm
almost positive koala bears have
chlamydia and great whites have herpes
there it is chlamydia listen the STD
threatened Australia icon yakety [ __ ]
with koala bears mmm
can human look at that chlamydia [ __ ]
look at me funny hey you behind the
bamboo branches come on alright check
that out read it I'm trying to read it
but I don't see chlamydia but numbers
are plumbing and survival equalities
under threat one of the reasons is a
sexually transmitted disease
chlamydia more months commonplace to buy
koalas in Australia days in the hospital
um no girl 300 koalas last year
chlamydia
so a lot of matters yeah yeah that's why
I was I have to cry why are they getting
it because they [ __ ] each other and they
don't wrap up condoms for koala bad cuz
they share needles Brian and people call
color combination we get them trying to
call cute gotta get them not up in here
you ain't fooling me so they have their
own form of chlamydia poison yeah causes
blindness infertility
well you know what not up in here where
conics first don't know why look at that
practice abstinence they need
Christianity
look at that Sabbats trying to entice
clothes off to their you know get all
close Oh
chlamydia with his [ __ ] 3 toes in
your face don't let me fool you Brian
hey look at me Australia not for you you
don't know all right let's go did you
know kangaroos has have AIDS HIV male or
not yeah and their tail now you're a
lineup you get hit with that tail aids
yeah so they say man you touch koalas
chlamydia not just one those poisonous
frogs herpes well poisonous frogs you
want to touch have you ever seen one of
those yes a lot Wow cuz ham can really
have yeah well no I think I'll speak
with you we didn't see any poison out
there or some I saw them and I'll salt
I saw poisonous [ __ ] I saw them in
there Indonesia and oh that's what I was
seeing this horse all right
ok Australia weird about chlamydia
[ __ ] from the koalas in a lady and
the ladies a certain bar how do you get
it from the Qantas they just touch you
does it say I only didn't get it only
with koalas and they don't know how wide
the koalas get it oh I heard I'm Pacific
another story rain open no hey hey hey
I'm good lost raelia got ya sorry about
my job a got herpes from the kangaroo
they call these antibiotics we got
chlamydia from the Koala rubbin noses
what else you got chin this one I just
found interesting that Amber Heard
is dating Elon Musk Oh check out the big
brain on must got him a dime piece
you know it's rare those big brains get
the Chairman jingim bro
why could be saving [ __ ] mankind yeah
yeah yeah who is hurt I'm sorry hey
Tesla on that Tesla a dick suck now who
has never heard she the one that just
divorced Johnny Depp remember oh oh and
if there's anyone to make you jealous
you're Johnny Depp
it's thank you good me one love Connor %
go from [ __ ] jack spirit you on mug
yep
you know what that girl is capable of a
big boy look at Elon oh not really he's
got a head on him but still well-done
use a bigger active to his head he's got
a brain on a man god damn is a head on
him yeah he's got a head on look at him
do well that's on a battery
well that's the worst picture that
hamburger I've ever seen make sure I can
man well this is this is a joke you
could be another girl you cross me
gorgeous but then you see her to a
certain angle and you're like I'm not
attracted to her at all anymore
why cuz you look like a star from born
this way that picture what is going on
right now
Wow Wow hey you got a John you there you
got a jolly good stuff don't let me kill
look at me don't get below me and look
up because I don't look as good as I do
straight on or when I'm over you that's
not a good angle for her oh it never
never talked to anybody shorter kids
must be like LA and then adults like
she's so hot that's just a bad picture
well her kneel on or there in Costa Rica
doing that that thing that we did with
the year ziplining ziplining do I go
ziplining [ __ ] that's so rude
no but we can go even with it ah sorry
the first one like damn this is cool by
the fifth one I was like oh never heard
bro
Amber Heard zipline into that man's
[ __ ] bank account
yep she's trying to she got a don't [ __ ]
with Elon Musk he had some work to do
you know I'm saying save mankind of dick
sucked and get out of the way yep Elon
Musk man you know you kids go to boxing
burg I thought about stealing him
so I five years younger
all right let's go that's the worst
picture for all time look at he's all
that's very tough can you get away get
that big guy to the next one is this a
twelve year old girl is set to fight a
24 year old at on the deep organization
deep is been up for a while I don't look
at that 12 year old it's a tiny little
girl it makes no sense to me and
dangerous the girl she's fighting 2 & 3
what if ya hit Tomas to losses mm-hmm
but 24 sis trying to get back in the win
column by taking on 12 year-old opponent
who's currently a 7th grader
she's a 95-pound yeah 95 pounds to $95
okay I don't approve too young
how do they even get this done should we
know that the trouble only weighs
roughly 86 pounds
boy Japan they don't they just leave him
for that freak show they don't you [ __ ]
what happens well you know Russia's got
those young kids swinging for the fences
- I don't know not like this not old
versus young it's usually a young guy
that Thailand does that America
everywhere does that base and this is
this is a sanctioned mixed martial arts
fight against two professionals Russia
doesn't do that now America doesn't do
that I don't we do young Russia Oh I
don't approve child labor laws what does
she just knock the [ __ ] out though her
name is Momo and the her opponents Momo
sake or something like that so that's
commanding have you have seen younger
kids do really well in jiu-jitsu because
I know the Lockean Jitsu yeah like when
I do those on an invitational there's
some young kids but also some 9 year
olds that were I mean it'll blow your
mind
oh really so they kill your ma she could
potentially win this fight then if she's
really good at yeah she's good Jitsu the
other girl seems to be you know maybe
this isn't for her she's 2 & 3
she's coming off two losses and she
looking to get back in the win column by
fighting a 12 year old the 24 I was a
former street fighter was bullied in
junior high school
get this off immediately I don't
suggestion I got one more
all right so husband saw his wife get
bitten by shark and he ended up punching
it in the face to get it off and then
apparently the shark went after him but
he bollocks them
but they both survived and she got
airlifted to the hospital I got a
picture of a great way to I don't think
was a great way did it do it too in say
what shark was so that's just a picture
of it yeah they say they have no idea
what Shawn you know what though look
where it's at though West Africa yeah
that's great white West Africa or South
Africa its West and it's uh the British
territory or whatever mm-hmm don't say
what happened her she's got her lifted
and then she's in the hospital with her
injuries damnation I didn't know knows
she's a known person to she works for
some sort of government thing I think
god damn it I think if I saw a pretty
wife like that I would have thought that
that's not the one I never heart attacks
great well what's this it's just the
same story but a different website
I like that great white so we're doing
oh I'm not doing Australia's snorkeling
[ __ ] no that ain't half [ __ ] no are you
out of your mind I did my wife what are
you talking about it Oh
get on the boat I'll jump in a cave a
white right there just this is a great
white sort of trying to go first a
surfer but then just turns back god he's
lucky where's it at right there we're
weird I don't right there
oh there desert oh [ __ ] so it's coming
at him and then he turns I'm gonna wait
to bat takes off saved his life oh [ __ ]
that strike said you know what man not
today sources you live here he comes
here he comes pretty big one here he
comes here he comes
it's not that big the little excu them
probably 60 or something
also the shark bit her leg she's been on
the leg so so they say that if you can
with a great white rather than punch it
grab its tail Oh what you know why
because that's what killer whales do and
when they grab you loses that be hi-oh
so which arc expert let's just go over
this real quick and just common sense
yeah so when the shark attacks it
doesn't come tale first come space night
now so use about six feet long when you
are that well let's just say an average
maybe six foot it's the little one yeah
how the [ __ ] would you grab it okay
did you ask cuz you're you're [ __ ]
done understanding you you vault over
its nose okay you vault over its nose
you don't give our fence stupid and then
you grab the tail and you go what's up
now [ __ ] you know who says
nothing a lot and runs away no one says
that you don't know you don't know
anything about you always taking their
eyes our heels and those I don't know
for sale okay killed yeah right you can
get up reveals no thanks dude
catch an angle and hid it in the gills
hook it in the gills at it Joey I said
will do Piper I'm done
you're dropping knowledge I have a
dropping knowledge if it's one from our
live show or about shark of a punch
genetic I just want to ruffle ah I see I
want to read something to you guys but I
think it's very important because it
goes back to certain things that I think
are important to know we have a very
divisive country politically right of
course we do in the 1850s there were no
bowl of cherries either I'm quoting
towards will but there's no denying that
a partisan division is very deep and the
level of discourse among thousands
policymakers in the media is bitter and
counterproductive so here's the bottom
line that we've always had in this
country a rich sort of history of
Federalists and Republicans and
Democrats being very nasty to each other
the election of 1800 was maybe the
nastiest ever remember Abraham Lincoln
was compared to eight and many of the
posters and stuff from the opposition so
that that that's not what matters I
think that what we're seeing now is this
when you pay attention to how people
argue for their side in politics or in
general what they do is this if you
notice that the right or the left always
kind of demonizes the other side they'll
call them pedophiles they call them
godless they call them scumbags
so you know what's lost in that whenever
I see that whenever I see someone like
our
Jones for example calling Hillary
Clinton saying that she kills children
and all that stuff like I'm not a fan of
Hillary Clinton's and I'm more
right-wing probably but the problem with
that is I always go you don't seem to
have a lot of faith in your own ideas
and here's why you should be trying if
you're really a conservative of you're
really a liberal or whatever it is you
should be trying to persuade the other
side to come over to your side or at
least persuade them to see that your
point of view has merit because if you
agree that we agree on the American Way
of life and we agree that we want a
better world for our kids and for
ourselves and a better country that
should be where we start from so instead
of like saying that you people over
there do all these bad things why don't
you do your best to try to get those
people to see that your point of view
might be the best way to solve these
problems and we don't do that enough and
whenever I see the other side and I
don't care if it's Fox News or at CNN
whenever I or Huffington Post The
Huffington Post is the liberal side Fox
News is the conservative side and both
of those sides love to take cheap shots
they love to belittle people that don't
agree with them and my problem with that
and by the way I guess who else did that
a lot Bill O'Reilly and Coulter does
that a lot and the left is very guilty
of that as well whenever I see that I
just think to myself man you don't have
a lot of confidence in your ideas you're
not very good at building bridges you're
definitely not part of the solution
you're part of the problem because all
you're doing is [ __ ] talking in your
echo chamber all you're doing is
speaking to your side you're not
speaking to the other side and try to
change their minds and what moves [ __ ]
forward and what solves problems and
what makes the world a better place is
getting the other side to see your point
of view and accept at least part of it
so don't call people names it's white
George Washington talked about civility
the founding fathers said civility is
very important and that means respect
for other people's point of view having
the wherewithal to listen and have the
respect to listen and not call people
names so that's going our names
shut up you stupid [ __ ] anybody's name
I can't acutally I'd like to do a man
who's always bother me from me I'm not
yes you are and I'm sent by their
warm-ups to ramble abuzz I think we've
been around each other maja man I have a
[ __ ] storm with I'm all wrong story
I'm gonna kill you
I'll fly you right now dude I wish you
would if you come I have your scalp and
yank of shitty hero I would never go
back oh man you you'd never grow back
Chad ready Wow Wow come on let's do this
faster you do it after man ah my finger
ah dross broke my finger dude sorry
You're not sorry dude sorry hey we're
coming for you just [ __ ] stay hot
with a broken finger
eventually right here Vancouver March
4th 5th and 6th I'm Lawrence fourth
fifth or sixth Wow I can't wait for that
keep clock you unless you're I saw a
third day I mean may as a comedy mix
I'll be you March 4th physics guess who
I'm going to be with the Azim brothers
Yosef and Tariq cool nut sell tickets I
love those guys though yeah I will be
May 3rd ice house comedy club breaking
down juicy 211 that sold out his won't
be welcome
I'm also sold out La Hoya of the Comedy
Store this Thursday is it I guess going
to be buying so got smaller clothes see
that Kate I call [ __ ] I love you
this is if I said we're out